quantum mechanics can be reduced down to
a canat shinger canat let's take a box
in the Box you put a cat and the
question is is the cat Dead or Alive
well until you open the box you don't
know it is alive and dead simultaneously
it's in a superp position of two states
in other words the universe has split in
half in one half the cat is alive in the
other universe the cat is Dead That's
the basis of the quantum theory that
until you make a measurement the cat can
exists in both States simultaneously in
fact in any number of states
simultaneously now why am I mentioning
this because this summarizes the power
of quantum computers quantum computers
compute on parallel universes that's why
they are so
powerful